one of my favorite series of all time
Deus Ex so Deus Ex mankind divided here
on stage yes please joining me now John
Francois Zhu God from idols John
Francois
we are here to talk about the future
talk about augmentations and I'm just
real excited to have you man how are you
doing great you thank you I'm doing very
well on stage at the square-enix show of
course early this morning yeah you guys
showing the things off to the world and
you got a demo to show that we're gonna
jump into here in a minute but let's lay
the stage for mankind divided you know
human Revolution ended with some pretty
dramatic events perpetrated by Adam
Jensen and took a shot at the shadowy
organizations but there's one thing I
know about shadowy organizations they
don't go away so easily and I guess
you're right actually we're two years
past human Revolution and now I've 38
the events you were talking about now
the world is way more divided than
before enstatite off and augmented
citizens are now seen as a threat for
the normal normal people and there's a
lot of fears and now governments are
enacting laws to make sure that those
people are put in ghettos as much as
possible and if they're not their life
is miserable among the other people
because now they're being appointed
persecuted exactly so it shows don't shy
away from that heavy stuff huh I guess
not but you grapple with it in such a
fascinating way it's one of the things
that I think people love about the
series is the way you take on you know
you use the the augmentation sort of
divide to cast light and to address
these big social issues absolutely I
think that that was important to to us
true entertainment true fiction to get
into the real stuff that is going in
real life and make hopefully maybe
people think a little bit about these
things yeah and but from the
entertainment standpoint Adam Jensen is
back like now he's not working for Cyrus
industries yeah who's paying this guy
it's an international country terrorist
agency called task force 29 it's a
subdivision tree
by Interpol okay and now Adam Jensen is
trying to fight the Kaos is trying to
bring some stability to the world but he
also has a double agenda like you said
like the people in the shadows they
don't go they don't go away easily is he
hopes through that agency gets he can
get closer to them and hopefully stop
them from shaping the world that way
they do stop them from yeah putting
their their hand on the wheel in such an
overt way yes yes so here we are like
launching into a mission we've got sort
of dropship taking us in you set the
stage for what we're gonna be what we're
gonna be seeing what's his metal boots
at the ground yeah absolutely well I
don't know if he's upgraded to metal
boots yet we don't know yet the a
depends on players right now he's going
to a complex or ghetto in the outskirts
of Prague that we have that place with a
section
yeah it's called golem City or the real
name it's the utili complex and it's a
get to where a lot of augmented citizen
or being put in cetera and there's a
faction there that is called the
Augmented Rights Coalition that is led
by a guy named Talos Rucker that are
trying to defend the rights of Augmented
people and trying to make sure that they
are not persecuted etc etc but early in
the game there's a big terrorist attack
that happens and guess what those are
the prime suspects and but they're in
this ghetto it's hard to get there even
like the police are just going at the
beginning of the ghetto they don't go
deep in uh-huh and you have to go and
blend in and try to find a way to get to
the guy and confront to confront him and
see if those people were behind the
attacks now we're gonna talk about
infiltration in a sec but yeah one of
the things that I think is wonderful and
sort of place to that conspiracy about
Deus Ex is the way that okay there's a
terrorist attack and these activists
were blamed for it but if they are you
know sort of activist for augmented
Rights
you know maybe someone setting them up
to smear them and then also if they're
activists for Augmented Rights you're an
Augmented dude like they're gonna make
their play on your loyalty and your
identity yeah and so I you know sort of
that's I think that's one of the
fascinating things you guys get into
absolutely and one of the thing we say
is that Adam Jensen when is in the
normal world let's say is in the street
of Prague or when he goes into this
ghetto we call him he's a stranger in a
strange land for different reasons
because when you go into the ghetto
people have problems it's more dirty a
sickness a shortage of the drugs they
need for the augmentation they don't
have top-of-the-line slick new augs like
exactly so when they see that guy like
you're not you're not part of us you
know because you're so shiny and
everything and when is in Prague one is
in Prague actually like is is an
augmented citizens IOU you don't belong
here go back in your ghetto kind of
thing so no matter where Jenson goes
it's not the welcome exactly but that
also gives him you know a unique
perspective and gives you guys a unique
perspective to work from now we're
looking at some stealthy infiltration
here absolutely like it's one of the
thing that so far in our communication
we showed a lot of the combat oriented
sequences and everything in today with
you guys we wanted to show that Stout is
still like alive and you can do the same
map or the same demo as we have a young
closed door but in a totally stealthy
fashion you can just go sneak around
use your cloaking use your smart vision
and outsmart vision has been updated
with you can know what the enemy's I
have like what kind of guns they have do
they have like kind of like we call
pocket secretaries with codes or things
like that so you can have more
information on the characters to decide
if you're going to go take down the guy
or not or you know that's kind of a nice
touch because you know I definitely
remember sort of all right I got a like
non-lethal takedown my way through all
these dudes till I find the keycard you
know my code that's not find the right
dude so I think just sort of giving
players more tools to do that kind of
scouting to do that kind of stealthy
approach and of course again you guys
are enabling a full stealth playthrough
absolutely from start to finish no
exception very no exception very cool so
you know but not everyone wants to do
the stealth thing like it's it's very
exacting sometimes it's sort of a puzzle
that a lot of people relish what I mean
come on man you've got these these these
arms these gun arms this color this
power these elbow bleh
that's times you just want a wreck house
exactly and and that was important to us
to really beef up the combat experience
to bring it on the same level as tell
because for a lot of players they
thought that their sex oh it it needs to
be placed stealthily and it's not and
for us that that's never been true it
needs to be played the way you want to
play it yeah you want it so it was
important that we made the the combat
more greedy those gun arms that Ark when
she that the way you play with your
augmentations it's faster than ever and
you'll be able to to sustain quite a lot
of intense dramas on a drum on-screen
yeah we're getting a little bit of drama
here that sort of triangular impingement
is that the Titan chill yeah is that the
one we just sort of looks like this
black mat exactly I'm a tree guy I don't
know how to describe it yeah it's true
nanotechnology and the as discover
shield now he can go in the open without
taking cover and just shooting at things
but of course your energy is going to
deplete so you're a vertically exactly
you have to manage it a bit but you're
going to be able to take way more risks
as you move forward into a mankind
divided definitely some cool new
augmentations on display one of my
favorite things actually in serious
history was the invisible war being able
to like maybe choose an augmentation
that some other guys developed it's
maybe like not quite the functionality
intended are you guys dabbling in the
black market at all anything shady
coming up through mankind divided it's a
very interesting question it's very
interesting alright alright I got you I
got you three five right there I don't
mean come on in a place like that it's
gotta be something shady going on always
something shady or conspiracy going on
behind the scenes in Deus Ex that's one
of the thrills of a series John Francois
thank you so much very much such a great
sport to talk to us about mankind
divided here at e3 2015 alright folks
we're gonna take a quick break up next
on the stage the show that kicked off
Microsoft's excellent press conference
yesterday halo 5 Guardians